salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien c'est Édouard je suis
journaliste pour brut alors il y a
quelques temps je vous proposais une
vidéo décryptage sur les coups d'État en
Afrique de l'Ouest au Burkina Faso on
vous mettra le lien en description
aujourd'hui c'est un grand plaisir pour
moi de revenir pour vous présenter un
documentaire sur la vie du légende
Thomas Sankara une icône qui fascine et
inspire la jeunesse aujourd'hui encore
Thomas Sankara c'est tout simplement le
père de la révolution burkinabè il a été
avant-gardiste sur plein de thématiques
que ce soit l'écologie le droit des
femmes ou l'indépendance de l'Afrique
vous verrez le réalisateur Yohan Malka
retrace plusieurs aspects de la vie de
Thomas Sankara ce documentaire a été
récompensé dans plusieurs festivals
c'est une fierté pour nous à bout de
vous présenter ce documentaire en deux
épisodes je vous laisse apprécier le
premier et n'oubliez pas laissez-nous
vos commentaires bon visionnage
tu connais Thomas Sankara toi tu connais
Thomas
dictateur
vous êtes là avec la publicité Lévis bon
c'est bien je vois le bruit d'une avec
c'est bien cousu à Lévis mais ça c'est
américain ouais même c'est en bas San
Francisco c'est écrit ça Francisco
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
lui il m'a l'air de bien connaître je
vais pas te mentir mais en tout cas je
sais que c'est un grand homme parce que
vu que on connaît tout son prénom c'est
qu'il a marqué l'histoire prenez Kalash
criminel
mais ça ça veut dire quoi c'est la
révolution petite bourgeoise des petits
bourgeois sont comme ça ils hésitent
tout le temps ils sont forts en théorie
nul en pratique
ça va ça s'arrête à là l'histoire des
Noirs c'est tout ce qu'on connaît
personnellement de l'école que j'ai
appris à l'école
j'ai parlé de l'escaravage après peu en
bas tu vois je suis je suis un rappeur
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a vraiment inspiré
dans la musique même dans mon discours
pour ça les gars renseignez-vous c'est
important pour faire vivre sa mémoire
fais attention à toi mon frère bonne
journée
à bientôt merci à vous je vous remercie
l'impérialisme les mauvais élèves les
mauvais professeurs la patrie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
camarade en avant pour la libération de
l'Afrique la patrouille
moi ce que j'aime bien dans Thomas
Sankara c'est son verbe laver des
punchlines comme on dit non
ce genre de personnage là il passe une
fois tous les centres la femme est une
femme révolutionnaire authentiquement
révolutionnaire
défendre la femme coûte que coûte qu'on
avait un modèle parfait de féminisme ici
mais au Burkina Faso
et ils sont nombreux ses ennemis c'est
d'abord le capitalisme international
n'est pas quoi et c'est pas la politique
de focus d'appui elle est là où ça
faisait mal quoi
[Musique]
une nuit
on tape à mon portail je me lève je vais
ouvrir c'est Thomas Sankara et Blaise
Compaoré qui sont arrêtés ils sont venus
à pied
je les reçois donc ce matin comme ça
et puis il me dit
va prendre le pouvoir et on va
transformer les choses dans ce pays
cette nuit là
qui est très jeune qui va réunir ses
forces
[Musique]
et qui va prendre le pouvoir et qui va
constituer une équipe de jeunes
incorruptibles pour révolutionner son
pays
[Musique]
allez parle-nous de notre enfant
avec ses compagnons qui étaient Blaise
Compaoré ils ont préparé du coup d'État
[Musique]
plus un homme de l'homme qui était plus
introverti qui parlait pas beaucoup mais
dont on disait qu'il était tout aussi
déterminé que Thomas Sankara
[Musique]
pense que je mourrais avec cette image
du militaire
frêle très déterminée dans le temps et
le regard
[Musique]
qui a pris la parole pour annoncer
qu'aujourd'hui 4 août 1983 on instauré
la révolution
il faut enterrer
tous les ennemis du peuple
tous les défauts qui empêchent le peuple
de se libérer c'est le peuple qui doit
construire le pays ce n'est personne
d'autre la révolution c'est pas un dîner
de gala c'est pas avec des queues de
pieds de nœud papillon qu'on fait la
révolution
les voleurs les voleurs c'est un
bouleversement violent
qui avait une classe politique et
pouvoir politique à renverser notre
pouvoir c'est limpide c'est clair il a
fait son choix il est du côté des
peuples
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les jeunes ont tout de suite épousé ce
mouvement là et l'homme prie à ras le
corps
tout de suite envahi la rue l'ont clamé
et ce sont proposés sans attendre qu'on
les appelle
en Afrique jamais à pouvoir ne s'appuie
sur la jeunesse tous les dirigeants du
pays ont une trentaine d'années ce qui
ne se reproduira plus jamais jusqu'à
maintenant
[Musique]
donner des responsabilités à ces jeunes
c'est une explosion d'énergie qu'il y a
à tout point de vue
[Musique]
le portrait du Sankara et j'ai tellement
fait ça des milliers de fois que je me
souviens de chaque détail de son visage
les yeux le nez les oreilles surtout le
béret qui est l'élément important
[Musique]
c'est clair que nous réclamons héritiers
de Sankara nourriture
engagé c'est pour ça que nous prenons
les risques de matérialiser son visage
parce que il y a pas longtemps on
pouvait pas le faire
ce qu'il a écrit
défense d'oublier
on n'a pas le droit d'oublier cet homme
la Patrie ou la mort nous verrons c'est
l'une des phrases quand on finit de la
réciter on a l'impression qu'il y a une
énergie qui traverse le corps
aujourd'hui on n'a pas un autre repère
Sankara il est plus que jamais présent
dans l'esprit de la jeunesse africaine
[Musique]
je voudrais simplement dire que nous
devons accepter de vivre africain
salut tout le monde J'espère que vous
allez
[Musique]
ça c'est américain moi-même
pour y arriver il a été à la tête de
mesurer radicale et de plus de position
à ton garder ce pour les Pâques
s'identifiant c'est super important
moi je sais que ma perception des choses
elle a changé quand j'ai quand je me
suis intéressé à Sankara tous les noirs
à un moment donné il se pose la question
de d'où on vient qui sont nos héros où
est-ce qu'on va comme on peut ranger les
choses à un moment donné tous les noirs
se posent cette question en tout cas en
France j'avais tellement à apprendre de
Tournes à Sankara et je le savais pas
c'est des choses que j'ai appris sur le
tard parce que c'est des choses qu'on
n'apprend pas à l'école à l'école
française en étant né ici c'est juste
que j'ai toujours eu une seule version
de l'histoire et que forcément je me
suis accroché à celle-ci et quand j'ai
découvert Sankara ça a remis en fait à
zéro un peu toutes mes références
notamment sur le féminisme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu crois que le Burkina fait partie des
rares pays commémore cette journée de 8
mars Journée de la femme qui est férié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vois que vous tenez une liste là où
c'est marqué
salade tomate etc cette liste là qui
voulait établi c'est ma femme qui
voulait
il faut que les hommes fassent le marché
et que les femmes restent à la maison
vous savez aussi faire la cuisine pour
la cuisine
la plupart des hommes ont rigolé et ben
on va aller voir pourquoi vous n'êtes
pas venu sur
[Musique]
la chaîne à la fois
parce que bon ce qu'il fallait acheter
bon
je connaissais pas donc elle me montre
comment elle me montre et puis je paye
et les femmes elle est presque mais s'il
vous plaît est-ce que ça vous fait
plaisir de sortir avec votre mari pour
venir au marché qu'il le paye les
condiments ça vous fait plaisir
puisque moi je le faisais seul
maintenant vous êtes
le faire seul aussi pour savoir les
difficultés qu'on a rencontrés aussi
quoi mais qui fait ça franchement qui
fait ça moi ça m'a fait mourir de rire
le jour où j'ai su à propos de cette
anecdote j'étais là non mais c'est grave
c'est à dire que le gars a appliqué son
programme à la lettre vous allez savoir
ce que c'est que l'expérience d'être une
femme en fait d'aller et de partager
finalement ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
la charge mentale et ben on va se
partager les on va se partager ça on
voit le féminisme comme un courant qui
est venu d'ailleurs parce que maintenant
quand on est féministe vous entendez des
féodaux nous dit non ça c'est sur les
blancs c'est chez les Blancs ça m'étonne
parce qu'on avait un modèle parfait de
féminisme ici même au Burkina Faso tu
dis mais aujourd'hui on est encore en
train d'écrire des tweets complètement
dingue pour juste affirmer ça lui il dit
ça on est en 84
[Musique]
après la semaine de
la soirée pour l'homme et la charte de
la famille la télévision locale lance
les colombes de la Révolution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vive la femme révolutionnaire voltaïque
la surprise vient du fait que c'est en
Afrique que un président donne des
leçons de ce qui doit être l'évolution
du monde notamment dans ce domaine là de
l'égalité
homme-femme c'est inédit je ne serai pas
qu'il se fait d'abord trop tard mais
aussi parce que les mariés réactionnels
en tant que vous veniez faire la cuisine
pour eux
les gens croient que c'est c'est pas
surjoué c'est nature comme ça c'est la
nature de toi
Arade il faut pas filmé que la femme
voltaïque est une femme révolutionnaire
authentiquement révolutionnaire
le premier gouvernement je crois que les
30% de femmes étaient déjà en acquis
vise la santé
familial et la solidarité nationale
c'est une femme plus de sport c'est une
femme
[Musique]
nous devons donner à chaque femme le
moyen de gagner honnêtement sa vie
et messieurs sont étudiés pour se
permettre aux femmes de recevoir de leur
mari par l'intermédiaire de l'État ce
que nous allons appeler le salaire vital
le salaire de l'homme se partager
désormais avec sa femme et ses enfants
au détriment de la bière au détriment
des bars
ialisme
[Musique]
je viens je suis né à une époque où les
pères africains étaient pas trop présent
ou alors ils avaient tendance un petit
peu à bifurquer et c'est vrai qu'on
s'appuie beaucoup beaucoup énormément en
fait sur le rôle de la maman en fait et
je pense que Thomas Sankara il devait
avoir cette fille ou il disait que la
femme elle a une importance capitale
parce que son enfant il a été marqué par
sa maman
[Musique]
on sent bien une empathie particulière
il a vu sa mère enfin il a vu toutes ses
femmes paysannes qui passent leur vie à
travailler tout ça ils n'ont pas comme
si le ressentait
la sensibilité qu'il avait vis-à-vis de
la libération de la femme était à fleur
de peau et dans tous ces discours il
exposait dans une même famille de
deux élèves une fille et un garçon quand
ils finissent quand il rentre à la
maison la fille elle a des travaux elle
doit faire la cuisine elle doit aider sa
mère à faire ceci est cela le garçon lui
semble aller s'amuser et ne revient le
soir que pour manger je pense que cette
tradition qui avait pour ambition de
faire de la femme un être qui doit
rester à la maison et s'occuper des
enfants de la famille à me mettait
attaquer pour la première fois au
Burkina Faso pas Thomas Sankara à
l'école même quand la fille quand les
filles sont en grossesse des choses
comme ça on les renvoie n'est-ce pas on
les exclut on le laisse lui le garçon
donc le garçon peut faire autant
d'enfants qu'il veut dès la 6e s'Il veut
Il commence à faire des enfants jusqu'à
en terminale on ira jamais mais la fille
même si elle est à un jour de son bac
elle fait un enfant Léo allez renvoyer
bon il faut à ce niveau là aussi par une
éducation sexuelle apprendre aux filles
et aux garçons chacun à connaître les
dangers les risques et de tel ou tel
acte
tu es en retard
les gens précoce là c'est surtout dû au
stress
[Rires]
il y a des gens c'est
3 à 5 secondes après la pénétration
Thomas Sankara disait qu'on ne peut pas
changer les choses sans une dose de
folie
pour moi porter le voile et parler de
sexualité c'est ma dose folie à moi
aussi donc vous pouvez considérer ça
comme une révolution pour moi ça reste
une nécessité
on intervient dans la sensibilisation en
ce qui concerne la santé sexuelle et
reproductive des adolescents et des
jeunes vous avez bien que c'est un sujet
tabou on en parle pas même nos propres
parents
vous avez opté pour une méthode comme ça
c'est petit
le préservatif c'est pour ça qu'on est
là ce matin vraiment vous sensibiliser à
utiliser des méthodes le préservatif
surtout
[Musique]
on ne peut pas ignorer les conséquences
de de
du manque d'information des jeunes en ce
qui concerne c'est difficile donc le
problème est là il faut l'affronter il y
a aussi ce volet féministe là dans ce
combat parce que de toute évidence
lorsqu'une grossesse suivi c'est la
femme qui est la victime
conseil en fait les jeunes de se rendre
dans des centres de santé spécialisé en
termes de sexualité pour avoir les
conseils qu'il faut parce que tous les
concepts contraceptifs ne vont pas avec
tous les organismes même le simple
préservatif il y en a qui sont
allergiques à ça
merci
prendre le pouvoir et toujours dans ce
domaine encore mon idole c'est Thomas
Sankara qui a il veut vraiment à capter
l'attention par la puissance du message
qu'il véhicule est
toute sa politique finalement c'est de
dire on est capable on est capable
d'avoir une autonomie une autonomie en
termes d'agriculture on est capable de
lancer le nouveau projet on parlait du
féminisme on est capable
et même l'écologie c'est à dire qu'il y
a le type il était tellement en avance
sur son temps
[Musique]
tous les lundis c'est le capitaine
lui-même qui mène les opérations de
reboisement utiles à son pays parce que
l'on dit que le désert gagne plus de 7
km par an dans notre pays ce n'est pas
visible mais il faut une campagne de
sensibilisation d'abord on a tous vu
[Musique]
l'impact écologique parce que ça a été
aussi sur ce terrain là un pionnier
avant l'heure bien avant que on prenne
conscience mondialement que on visse
l'une même terre et que ce qui se fait
ailleurs comme à Kent à l'environnement
aller avoir des conséquences aussi bien
ici qu'ailleurs de dire on importe pas
le riz qui vient d'Asie encore
aujourd'hui on est dans ce problème
aujourd'hui en Afrique de importer du
lait qui mais au final est frelaté enfin
bon bref on se retrouve dans des
scandales comme ça parce que on importe
un maximum de choses et qu'on produit
plus sur place lui il avait déjà ça en
tête je pense que à l'époque oui il a dû
faire il a dû faire peur à plus d'une
personne en France
la participation du camarade président à
la conférence internationale sur l'arbre
et la forêt est une occasion pour
relancer le dialogue avec la France dans
l'amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne beaucoup
de regards sur le capitaine Sankara le
capitaine Sankara a dénoncé
cé
et la société aujourd'hui on est
sensible à l'écologie mais sauf que lui
ces problèmes ils étaient là déjà la
sécheresse elle était là la
déforestation elle était là puis il a
répondu directement au soucis qui se
posait devant lui parce que c'était
vital
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est très actuel c'est
vrai que c'est un visionnaire un peu
voir un message messianique dans dans
son discours et moi je pense que c'est
la nécessité surtout il sera interdit
de couper le bois
désormais tout véhicule
transportant du bois sera arrêté
et des amendes
seront prononcés contre le propriétaire
du véhicule et nous permettrons ainsi à
la nature de se reproduire de façon
harmonieuse ici on a vu
qu'en quelques temps même des espèces de
faune etc qui avait disparu était devenu
dans certains villages moi dans mon
propre village les gens ont vu qu'en 4
années où il y a pas eu cette coupe
abusive du bois etc on a vu la
régénération du sol c'est l'avenir qui
se dessine et Thomas était un pionnier
voilà vous êtes là avec la publicité
Lévis faites la publicité de Lévis
bon c'est bien je vois le bruit d'une
avec c'est bien cousu à Lévis c'est bien
mais ça c'est américain moi-même c'est
un marqué en bas San Francisco c'est
écrit
comment on va faire
[Musique]
doit avoir ses propres lunettes pour
regarder le monde
[Musique]
donc matérialiser le consommant local
consommons burkinabè comme l'a voulu
Thomas Sankara
il n'y a pas un seul fil qui vient de
l'Europe ou de l'Amérique
slogan
la ville de Ouagadougou disait ceci
produisons et consommons burkinabè
[Musique]
transformons ce que nous produisons ce
que nous consommons
c'est dire que il va pas continuer à
manger
la mendicité c'est fini on se sauve
soi-même on n'est pas sauvé par
quelqu'un malheureusement par manque
d'organisation nous sommes encore
obligés de tendre la main pour demander
des ex alimentaires ces alimentaires
installe dans nos esprits cette habitude
c'est réflexes de mendiants d'assister
il est normal que celui qui vous donne à
manger vous dites également
c'est volonté il y en a qui demande mais
où se trouve l'impérialisme
l'impérialisme regarder dans vos
assiettes quand vous mangez les graines
de riz de maïs de 1000 importés ça
l'impérialisme elle est pas plus loin en
4 ans on a pu pour la première fois
depuis les indépendances atteindre
l'autosuffisance alimentaire on a
construit le plus grand barrage de ce
pays qui a permis de passer de 300
millions de mètres cubes à 600 millions
de mètres cubes sans un franc d'être
extérieur
c'est pas quelque chose ça
il répond aux besoins du peuple il
répond aux besoins essentiel lui il dit
qu'il faut donner à manger tous les
jours aux gens il faut leur donner à
boire etc il crée un modèle je vais dire
de développement et donc il est
effectivement très populaire
vue de France on a toujours pris les
présidents africains un peu comme des
Guignols j'ai envie de dire ça quoi
c'est cette image là en fait qu'on a du
président africain dans ces années-là
quand on prend par exemple Bokassa en
Centrafrique il s'auto proclame empereur
une cérémonie juste je pense que le prix
de la cérémonie d'investiture c'est
probablement le PIB de son pays et des
pays voisins
couronne de laurier d'or jean-bodel
Bokassa va devenir Bokassa premier
empereur de centrale
c'est la même chose pour un Mobutu au
Zaïre
on reste sur cette figure de président
qui avait des palais complètement dingo
moi j'ai vu mon bouton
c'est ça aussi d'imaginaire que les
élites politiques ont semé dans les
esprits
moi un président africain dans ma tête
franchement c'est
c'est tout ce que je déteste en fait
c'est tout ce qui nous montre que
finalement on va on va vraiment avoir du
mal à franchir ce palier pour pouvoir
vraiment devenir un état ou un continent
qui va compter en fait Thomas Sankara il
avait cette vision et en opposition on a
tous les dominions tous les chefs d'État
africains qui en fait pensent d'abord à
s'enrichir personnellement plutôt que
que 10
000 de tout ça il habite toujours dans
son petit quartier est-ce qu'il faut il
rentre à vélo même chez lui et parce
qu'en fait il est proche du peuple il
est le peuple en fait
[Musique]
noter à la prod
c'est ça
ce [__] de rap on néglige mais il
avance elle n'écoute pas les aiguilles
qui viennent te
pourquoi le Burkina Faso pourquoi avoir
voulu changer le nom de la Haute-Volta
c'est un nom qui ne nous renvoie qu'à un
passé colonialiste par contre Burkina
Faso est un nom puisé dans le terroir
même qui a une signification dans notre
langue qui veut dire
patrie des hommes
[Musique]
faut oser aussi appeler un pays comme ça
faut dire que franchement c'est 1000
fois mieux que Haute Volta en nous
appelait des voltaïques comme les piles
photovoltaïques
[Musique]
[Rires]
héritage du colonialisme français
[Musique]
tout de suite tout le monde le comprend
tout le monde l'a accepté
[Musique]
la révolution si elle promet un avenir
radieux
elle part d'abord de sacrifices de
sacrifice permanent et c'est sacrifice
nous sommes décidés à les assumer
c'est sacrifice nous avons demandé aux
fonctionnaires de renoncer à une partie
de leurs indemnités parce qu'ils sont
des privilégiés Thomas Sankara ton
salaire était connu c'était moyen de 200
000 francs Cfa donc moins de 200 euros
moi qui vous parle j'ai déjà fait quoi
j'avais même pas 200 € par mois en tant
que ministre pendant 4 ans mais je m'en
suis pas prêt je me pliais pas le
ministre ne sont pas autorisés à voyager
en classe première en première classe
dans les avions ils prennent les classes
touristes et même quand il est possible
de voyager par les avions Uncharted nous
faisons
plus belle que jamais raffiné dans les
moindres détails super équipé des pieds
à la tête
[Musique]
mercredi jour de réunion du Conseil des
ministres ceci s'y rendre dans leur
nouveau véhicule de fonction en effet là
aussi pour montrer qu'on veut rompre
avec d'anciennes habitudes d'anciens
privilèges les Mercedes symboles du
pouvoir utilisés par les précédents
régimes ont été remplacés par des R5
vous vous avez eu l'air 5
j'ai quitté une 550
[Musique]
ce que Thomas n'est supporté surtout pas
c'est l'accumulation excessive de bien
personnel
la maison paternelle est toujours là
vous pouvez la voir encore dans le
quartier de Poya
[Musique]
il avait une biclette
il avait une guitare parce qu'il aimait
jouer de la guitare il les met se mettre
avec d'autres jeunes pour jouer
[Musique]
et
je crois que c'était tout
c'est quand même ouf qu'un gars il est
décidé de s'appauvrir de galérer de
donner sa vie pour faire avancer les
choses
c'est un homme qui était vraiment
sensible à la misère de son peuple et il
disait dans ce sens par exemple il faut
choisir entre le champagne pour
quelques-uns et l'eau potable pour tous
c'est lui qui l'a dit il préfère que
l'eau pourtant pour tout le monde plutôt
que le champagne pour quelques-uns c'est
fort quand même ça parle de ce point de
vue je pense que ce n'est pas de
l'égalité ce n'est pas du populisme non
c'est du réalisme
[Musique]
ils sont montés au pouvoir très jeune ça
bouillonnait de partout il fallait
expérimenter tout toutes les idées et je
crois que ça allait un peu trop vite
il a fait un plein de petites erreurs en
fait
tu me retrouves un peu comme un cycliste
qui grimpe une pente raide
qui a à gauche à droite de précipice il
est obligé de pédaler de continuer de
pédaler sinon il tombe
alors pour rester moi-même et pour me
sentir moi-même je suis obligé de
continuer dans cette lancée là
quand on utilisait le marquer que ça va
trop vite
il disait mais
c'est un combat de vie ou de mort où
nous réussissons pour nous disparition
[Musique]
vous vous sentez isolé en Afrique mal
compris en tout cas mal compris mal aimé
mal de dos
Sankara il dérangeait trop tu vois il
était trop
extrême dans sa façon de vouloir lutter
contre la corruption trop extrême dans
sa façon de vouloir stopper certains
avantages qu'avaient certaines personnes
et ça je pense que c'est ça qui vraiment
qui la qui l'a tué parce qu'en fait les
brise ennemis de Sankara ils étaient à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que vous avez aimé la
première partie de cette vidéo vous
inquiétez pas on vous laissera pas très
longtemps sur votre fin car la deuxième
partie sera disponible dès demain sur la
chaîne Youtube de brut vous verrez dans
cette deuxième partie le tournant qui a
mené à l'assassinat de Thomas Sankara
notamment avec la trahison de son ami et
frère en Blaise Compaoré je vous en dis
pas plus je vous donne rendez-vous dès
demain